how's that
I failed you right visual arts can you
tell all right there's a fridge okay and
it's got water placed inside by the way
they call the fridge zero degrees
Celsius that's kind of interesting
because you guys know probably that a
fridge is not zero Degree sausage they
don't know what really is yet negative
three or four roughly tends to be four
uh I'll let you have a think about why
they've deliberately not made at
negative four and how you'd have to
change things if it was anyway the
fridge is zero degrees lost my spawn
page and what it cools is proportional
to its temperature so they're calling H
the temperature okay so therefore what
equation can i fault if the temperature
drop is proportional to the temperature
and it's it's dropping right because
things are going towards zero degrees
then the statement I would make will be
just like this right it would be D H on
DT right what's it equal to
it's a decay situation it's maybe noon
you're gonna get whatever the constant
of proportionality is okay and it's
proportional to the temperature I think
they mean H for heat and yes okay so
Part A I don't show that a standard
equation is so that this is a solution
we've been through this before okay so
let's have a go let's do th on duty just
to make it so that I have an extra step
in here I tend to show the derivative
like this so I'm not actually just
writing down what this is okay so now I
stick that up front
and that's negative K H because there's
H okay so therefore it satisfies the
differential equation okay they always
start like that
papi find the initial temperature or
find H naught
given that the liquid is initially a
hundred degrees I'm going to kind of
skip over that because I think you guys
I've sort of done that to death H no
it's your initial temperature so that's
what that's 100 reads they're putting
some boiling water and there's my cut
that's why it's TV ok after 5 minutes
after 5 minutes the temperature has
dropped to 40 degrees so again I'll just
draw myself a little equation here that
says 100 degrees - what did you say 40
degrees degrees in 5 minutes ok so this
is what happens this is what takes place
so what equation is going to correspond
to this that will help me work out some
other constants what should I write
is the equation are working in right H
is my changing temperature indicator so
now let's come down to 40 my H nodes are
hundred so I'm just going to start that
in there and what did we say five
minutes so this is e to the minus of
five K now I should have said right at
the beginning here right they state this
I'm so used to writing a Zed there okay
so keep that in mind we're going to pull
that out in a second
what do I do with this how do I get K
out of the index I should divide write a
40 over a hundred you can do a bit of
that in head country what is it gonna
simplify down to two bits yeah that's e
to the negative 5k right so now what I
can take a lot of both sides right so
I'm going to get log of 2 over five here
I'm gonna get just the power there so
now I want K on its own like so and now
I pause it's always good whenever you
got situations like this whenever you
can you think okay does my answer make
sense as I go through it'll help you
sort of debug rather than get to the end
I have the wrong answer and have to pin
all the way back through your steps okay
now does this make sense there's this
seem like a plausible value from hey now
it is a plausible value but you might
think there are some problems with it
because I just laid it over the point
that K is positive okay even when you've
got a decay situation or a growth
situation whichever it is this is meant
to be a constant portion allottee just
tells you the speed rather than the
direction of change okay but there is a
brighter side on the front why is there
a minus sign on the front
okay so logs right as a billion isn't it
logs can be negative depending on
whatever is in their log of two-fifths
this is a very small value over here so
a lot of truth is is actually negative
right I suppose you could write it if I
were to get rid of the negative what
would it look like
it'll be 1/5 come on use your log voice
what's gonna become 5 or 2 right because
it's 2 fits to the power of negative 1
okay you could write it like that it
just so happens because what I'm gonna
put it back into already has a negative
there this negative and this negative
will cancel so you actually don't gain
anything by rewriting like this even
those so nice song but just so you know
yes it is positive so there's my analogy
for K you could stick it into your
calculator and get a decimal help but
there's not really much to gain there
anyway because you want something exact
Pardy I think I want to know the
temperature after 15 minutes
yeah ok so when that's the temperature
so we're going to slap it into our page
and heater right we've got our value for
H naught we've got our values for K you
could play
ok h equals H naught there 100 right
each of the now because we've got the
dead double negative here right I'm
gonna get rid of them so I'm gonna have
a bit log 2 over 5 times 15 SATA right
so that's a hundred I'll do a bit of
tidying up here 8 a power of 3 log 2
over 5 you can put that into your
calculator yeah yeah
you can't put that into your calculator
but you do remember the trick that I
showed you yesterday about simplifying
getting rid of eat and logs together in
order make this just a bit simpler how
could we do this this three again using
what we saw - yup
write this so you can come up into the
power this is really log of two bits
cube data cake you see how I've changed
the position of the coefficient so
reference each of them or whatever is
just whatever okay which is a bit easier
to put any calculator and even really
need to put that in back of you that's a
hundred times yeah
come on surely a week I know you don't
have to do this but use your brain come
on you're 12 you often don't have to do
sort of calculations like this so let's
give it a jerk / five easy that your
head yes you can that's six point four
well done Wow my brain can still do
numbers that's incredible okay this is
implausible is that a sensible answer
yeah I think so I mean we did say we're
heading towards zero degrees it's been
in there for a little while that's a
pretty cold water okay great